.
>>> SOMEF THE MEMPHIS POLICE
OFFICERS FACING SECOND-DEGREE
MURDER CHARGES RELATED TBRUTAL
KILLING OF TYRE NICHOLS WERE
MEMBERS OF THE SO-CALLED
SCORPION UNIT.
AN ATTORNEY FOR THE FAMILY SAID
THAT THE CITY SHOULD PEAD
IMMEDIATELY DISBAND THAT GROUP.
WE'RE GETTING NEW INFORMATION.
WHAT ARE YOU LEARNING.
>> THIS UNIT HAS NOT BEEN IN
EXISTENCE FOR VERY LONG BUT HAS
A HISTORY OF THE CONTROVERSY AND
TND THE ATTORNEYS FOR TYRE
NICHOLS CALLING ON THE POLICE
CHIEF TO TAKE THE SWIFTEST, MOST
DECISIVE ACTION AGAINST THAT
UNIT.
>> I'M ASKING CHIEF DAVIS TO
DISBAND THIS SCORPION UNIT
EFFECTIVE IMMEDIATELY.
>> IMMEDIATELY.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> THE INTENT OF THE SCORPION
UNIT HAS NOW BEEN CORRUPTED.
>> SCORPION STANDING FOR STREET
CRIMES OPERATION TO RESTORE
PEACE IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS HAVE
A SPECIALIZED UNIT OF THE
MEMPHIS POLICE CREATED BY THE
CURRENT CHIEF IN THE FALL OF
2021.
WITH A PROMO VIDEO ACCOMPANYING
ITS LAUNCH.
CHIEF DAVIS TOLD OUR DON LEMON
THEY NEEDED A UNIT TO ADDRESS A
SURGE OF VIOLENT CRIMES IN
MEMPHIS.
>> THIS IS ONE OF THREE TEAMS
WHOSE PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITY IS
TO REDUCE GUN VIOLENCE, TO BE
VISIBLE IN COMMUNITIES, AND TO
ALSO IMPACT THE RISE IN THE
CRIME.
BASICALLY OUT OF AN OUTCRY FROM
THE COMMUNITY, WE HAD RECORD
NUMBERS IN 2021, 346 HOMICIDES.
>> Reporter: CHIEF DAVIS SAID
THE SCORPION UNIT HAD GREAT
SUCCESS.
>> LAST YEAR, IT WAS THE FIRST
YEAR IN A LONG TIME THAT WE HAVE
REDUCTIONS.
>> Reporter: THE MAYOR'S OFFICE
TOUTED THE EARLY SUCCESS SAYING
THAT BETWEEN THE INCEPTION IN
THE FALL OF 2021 THROUGH 2022,
THE UNIT MADE 566 ARRESTS AND
SEIZED 270 VEHICLES AND OVER
$100,000 IN CASH.
BUT IN ITS BRIEF LIFETIME, THERE
IS ALSO A HISTORY OF TENSION
BETWEEN SCORPION OFFICERS AND
THE COMMUNITY.
ATTORNEYS FOR TYRE NICHOLS'S
FAMILY SAY THAT UNIT GOES AROUND
IN UNMARKED CARS AND IS
SOMETIMES UNNECESSARILY
AGGRESSIVE.
FAMILY ATTORNEY BEN CRUMP
RELATED ONE ACCOUNT THAT A LOCAL
MAN HAD DESCRIBED TO MEDIA
OUTLETS OF HIS EBB COUNTER WITH
SCORPION.
>> THERE IS A BROTHER WHO SAID
FOUR OR FIVE DAYS BEFORE THIS
HAPPENED TO TYRE, THAT SAME
SCORPION UNIT CONFRONTED HIM
WHEN HE WAS IN HIS CAR GOING TO
GET PIZZA AND HE SAID THAT THEY
USED ALL KIND OF PROFANITY
AGAINST HIM, THEY THREW HIM ON
THE GROUND, TALKING ABOUT WHERE
ARE THE DRUGS AND WHERE ARE THE
WEAPONS.
>> Reporter: AND CRUMP SAID THE
OFFICERS POINTED A GUN AT THE
MAN'S HEAD.
CNN HAS REACHED OUT TO THE
MEMPHIS POLICE FOR RESPOND TO
THAT ACCOUNT.
WE HAVEN'T HEARD BACK.
ONE LAW ENFORCEMENT VETERAN
DESCRIBED ISSUES THAT OFTEN CROP
UP WITH SPECIALIZED UNITS IN
CITY POLICE DEPARTMENTS.
>> GENERALLY SPEAKING, WHEN WE
HAVE AN ENFORCEMENT DRIVEN UNIT,
THESE UNITS RACK UP COMPLAINTS
AGAINST THEM BASED ON EXCESSIVE
FORCE BUT THE TERMINAL PIECE IN
THIS IS OVERALL SUPERVISION.
SO I BELIEVE THAT WE HAD A
FAILURE IN SUPERVISION AND THERE
WAS NO APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT TO
ENSURE THAT THESE OFFICERS WERE
DOING WHAT THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO
DO.
>> Reporter: AGAIN, THE MEMPHIS
POLICE DEPARTMENT HAS NOT
RESPONDED TO SPECIFIC
ALLEGATIONS OF PREVIOUS USE OF
EXCESSIVE FORCE BY THE SCORPION
UNIT BUT THE MEMPHIS POLICE DO
TELL CNN THAT UNIT AND ALL OTHER